[Music]
and let it grow you let it grow let it
grow
I'll cut your pubes and evil let it grow
submitted by Mystery Men is David
cynical a religious leader has declared
that men want to protect themselves from
homosexuality they should not shave
their beards why cos gave me but unlike
beards
that's stupid just plenty of gay guys
with beards that's all true
well what if you can't even grow beard
doesn't make you gay from their
perspective facial hair Ward's off gay
men they gave a pub cording to these
guys stuff like that make me wonder like
where did he even give us facts how
could you even connect no cheating is
the story of Samson
so Samson was a very strong man and God
gave him the strength and it was in his
beard remember I wasn't here those long
hair Delilah's shagged him any kind of a
she's right [ __ ] them especially without
beard and then he could have [ __ ] he
couldn't bring down the [ __ ] City
yeah I don't think it was his hair
though I really think cuz she made him
come thought it is not him every week
I can't jack off the night before a
[ __ ] heavy lift man the next morning
I'm just not that strong
another thing you know in my high school
you are supposed to like masturbate
before it sports me Ronda Rousey's issue
was not before my night remember that
good for women the girls masturbated and
he performed that they actually have
massage therapists that come to make all
the girls orgasm so pretty much a gigolo
they would hire guys to [ __ ] them before
an Olympic event I think it was a
masturbation so there's a combined dirty
trick they all con they all be Mason
like I dunno one thanks for lucky 92
year old James like almost like real men
I just got a your spit though it was so
sprayed that's really just leader what's
his name Gandalf I don't want it
he must have the longest of beards you
not a man nor Nellie oh I don't know his
name or I don't know what's going on
your prophet is always really wondering
is it such a stupid earring you're your
fake [ __ ] name
I am the primate of the Russian Orthodox
Old Believers church with an which is
and Orthodox Catholic sect that left the
church back in 1666 1666 there's three
sixes in there so mark got an Abba well
how do you what church are you leaving
if we're still the Orthodox Catholic
Church that's like the og that's a
triple og that's like calling yourself
were the original original original but
we left so original original original
original they're saying that the
Orthodox Catholic Church was making
changes to the books and the customs of
that religion is so vague that
particularly Durr didn't like that so
then you removed himself and his group
from the Catholic Orthodox Catholic
Church and then created his own I want
everyone to believe them though like I
wonder the people that like he's
preaching to actually is like that's
what I'd only be gay yeah it makes
people stupid as [ __ ] oh that's that so
there's menacing quotes God gave us the
rules it is written that God created
every one with a beard a Catholic West
has completely fallen away from this
concept but this is clear the icons we
cannot imagine Christ or some Saint
without a beard one should not oppose
its creator it's made a most month
monstrous thing to see men's clothing
and hairstyles
chandi just don't like fashion the old
fashion [ __ ] anything that the practice
of beard shaving is a departure from the
sacred and holy so if they think
Buddha's gaiters yeah they probably
think Buddha's flaming hot cheetos
that's all they has like one strap on
his shoulder and the other shoulders
exposed and that is between your saving
you're like look at that fat gay guy all
right everybody looks like their clothes
about to fall off they're like a sexy
silk lingerie [ __ ] and they're just
laying sideways like this some sexy ass
creatures oh that's right they look like
girls in the movies after they [ __ ] but
they're trying to just cover themselves
up a little bit it was weird though
cause like what about the people of the
church who can't grow beard like they're
not going to like go out of their way to
try to look for like maybe this dude's
wrong
Oh ethnic group of Haitians that are
looking at this right now like this what
about I can grow three hairs out of this
[ __ ] mole that's my dear what is the
Asian thing about figures your wives or
some Weiser's money yeah our big luck
money lot loves like the low bulbs yeah
yeah if you're good luck or something my
mom is to make me stretch my ears okay
talk about better luck I knew that 2% I
wasn't no get beat up a lot when your
kid there I think my ears are
self-consciousness what's wrong tears oh
I don't care about them anymore but
these two go a little bit oh my God look
at that not getting this normally is
know before I like showing my ears was
like showing you like my boobs why don't
you get surgery and make wishes come out
even more did you get surgery to make
the ears come out even more single puffy
powder room I'm okay with the way they
are now also people never get perfect
stories of doctor [ __ ] up why would you
do that I do I mean the cat lady the
lizard guy they're trying to achieve a
level of beauty so you know there's
girls I get their ears pinned back or do
whatever why don't why don't they put it
forward or get their nose and then make
it like like Radner knows the media like
this I bet you said the cat woman on the
other side but the achieving their level
of beauty though that's their level of
beauty want to go backwards like
someone's too hot I want to know what it
feels like to be ugly as [ __ ] let me
like the great dishes oh do you know
what that's true
yo you know all those people out there
all those chicks right oh let's say this
you don't know how hard it is to be
beautiful sometimes I wish I was ugly
you don't have to wish I'll fund that
for using one girl said that [ __ ] all
right so Instagram shirts are like oh my
god is so hard is they basically say
it's hard being beautiful like you judge
me because I'm so pretty and my thing
about it is like you say that because
you don't know what it's like to be ugly
what is right about being beautiful it's
cuz like there's a certain expectation
and it's like more money more problems
like that so you don't get taxed on
video some reason I thought nobody I
feel like everybody's got some kind of
ugly in them
Oh everyone's got a little bit of beauty
and a little bit of ugly in them or
physically physically too there's no one
that flawless like some people
photograph really
well but also I've seen some [ __ ] where
I was like damn and then like a cinnamon
person your life you know yeah that's
always just like a different beauty
standard for different people gal gadot
though she is when you were talking
about the not perfect she popped into my
head I'm like machine no matter how hot
anyone is give me a duration of time
with them I'll be bored of them I'll be
like you [ __ ] ugly sack of [ __ ] shut
up I'll find something I know nobody is
perfect and no one can stay amazingly
[ __ ] perfect
how are we gonna tallest spot she looks
like she's like me like six five I'm not
sure but somebody told me she's like
fine 11 appointment but she's really
told me there's much fun in the fact
that she's so good can I see who
Galactica's everyone says that look I
have so many messages of everyone saying
like you look like her you look like
from like oh brain after we just said
she's the most beautiful woman in the
world you conceited [ __ ] you do look
like her a little bit smaller eyes beard
yeah well if you show me your [ __ ]
face [ __ ] what are you going to do
hello
I got a completely unbiased you can't
deliver later glad is make your eyes in
size look bigger but then if you take it
off it looks like this is it right now
huge a make sure I just I look bigger
[ __ ] [ __ ] ruin my woman down thank
you very much
it was weird hearing you say that
because people were telling me I look
like her like oh [ __ ] you're gonna ruin
my fantasy thank you ho well I gotta
ruin the same thing yeah just not
straight but I did I know the better
it'll be oh my god
I got a message saying like oh I was
watching a JK muse and my mom came in
and said that who's that girl she looks
like Wonder Woman but they send it to me
and I'm like no I think she's talking
about jihad I didn't no way I look
anything like there's Galactica latina
no she's really she's a Jewish girl she
was five months pregnant while she was
filming what what I'm not for sure for
the whole he was yeah the director will
be fed information she has a green like
mark cut out for her belly so she was
talking about it she was five months
pregnant she's getting kicking this
coming that's a real Wonder Woman right
there
well you will film me when you're five
months pregnant - yeah you want to doing
no Wonder Woman [ __ ] though haha she was
sitting down and talking about very very
passionately you're my wonderful success
but deserves it in your womb give them a
child you know the pattern just have to
see absol hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discuss just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video let's wrap up
[Music]